a signature and then a handshake for
what depending on perspective is either
a stabilizing security pact or as China
describes it the latest round of a
dangerous geopolitical game the argument
that we're signing today is
that's enough
USA law is mutually beneficial the U.S
Secretary of State was in portmore's
Beyond behalf of Joe Biden who canceled
his visit to hold debt crisis talks in
Washington Anthony blinken is adamant
the deal is not a threat to anyone the
defense cooperation agreement drafted by
the park New Guinea in the United States
as equal and Sovereign Partners will
enhance the png's defense
transportation's capabilities to deliver
humanitarian assistance and disaster
relief included through providing
Medical Care and temporary shelter to
those who are affected by crisis that
focus on sovereignty was deliberate
there is concern that opening the door
for a greater U.S military presence
could lead to the us having unilateral
power within Papua New Guinea's
territory and that a new military deal
could be viewed as provocative towards
China there is this sense in the region
that there's friction geopolitical
friction between the larger Powers this
time last year China agreed a defense
Accord with the Solomon Islands the U.S
and its allies were caught by surprise
over the last 12 months in particular
we've seen strong interest from
Washington
to re-engage in the Pacific to to
refresh relationships that had been
neglected for four decades to create new
ones and to build a more visible
presence for itself China's presence is
already visible across the region
president Xi Jinping made a very high
profile visit to Papua New Guinea in
2018 much of its recent infrastructure
has been built with Chinese money
in that context the visit by India's
prime minister also on Monday is
significant Narendra Modi has placed
economic support and assistance in
tackling climate change
Modi will come here to Australia next
with President Biden canceling his visit
to the region it is significant that an
ally a man described by Papua New
guinean prime minister marape as the
leader of the global South has still
made the trip it seems rivalry is
economic as well as military Andrew
Thomas Al Jazeera Sydney